how much convincing did you take lady
gaga to do this because it's a big leap
it took no convincing on my part I mean
he came over to my house and we had a
wonderful time together I mean as soon
as he came in we're both from the East
Coast and we're both italian-american so
I was like heating up or pasta from the
night before in the kitchen on the
frying pan we were eating on the patio
talking about life and family and then
he wanted to sing with me song by
Creedence Clearwater Revival midnight
special so I was playing it on the piano
and he started to sing and I was like oh
my gosh Bradley your voice I was blown
away by him I mean he just he sings from
his soul he sings from his gut and when
he sings he's a storyteller and I was
just so moved by his passion you know
for for that for music and for this film
and quite frankly it was him that had to
convince other people to have me in the
movie not anyone trying to convince me I
mean he really fought for me and you can
have a hundred people in the room that
are watching you and 99 don't believe in
you and one does and that was him so you
know
[Applause]
[Music]
you